Yes, so you, you share with us four different propositions concerning reconciliation among, in between faiths and I kept thinking each time you
said the word "faith" that I could potentially substitute any other sort of
0:00:26.079,0:00:31.300
identity marker instead, so, for instance, you were talking about exclusivist faiths, but I could also think about
political groups or cultural groups or linguistic
groups that are also incredibly exclusivist
and
because of that exclusivism they have a
really hard time coming together and, and, and producing improvements for the world.
So, the question is,
is there anything distinct about the process of religious
reconciliation as opposed to reconciliation between
other types of
groups that are also competing, whether they're political
or cultural or any other sort of
identity, based on any other sort of identity. I
don't know what,
what you think, but I mean I think,
first of all in a sense for me it's enough religious faith is such a,
you know,
is, is, is such a,
an identity marker.
Cause that,
if it's important then one should deal with it.
I think there is an intensity about religious belief that distinguishes it,
doesn't always distinguish it, I mean, some people could be
intense about their football club.
Now,
crazy people get about
sport in this country, but in my country, you know,
there's a team, a team I support, people, actually,
I remember a guy going on T.V.
and saying
my football team is more important to me than my wife or my children. I remember sitting there, I can't what.
This is ridiculous.
But,
so I agree there are, there are other,
I think, but I think that there is a,
there is more often an intensity about religious faith
and I also think
a lot of these other identity markers kind of come and go,
but this is with us.
You know, religious
conviction is not diminishing, actually, it's one things we
discovered early on in the course, so I think it's still very,
very important,
but, I mean, you're right, you could
translate some of that elsewhere. What would you? Nationalism strikes me as, as sometimes the sentiment that trumps faith.
If I, If I look at American sensibilities often
from the outside, I may not understand America really well, but it seems to me
often that America
is the most important religion too many
people
of, of the religious right and so forth. Notwithstanding all the protestations,
it really, America does the, the, the real work
of, of loyalty and if, if you have a competing loyalty America's going to.
Right, but is the point that Angelica makes, does that, in a sense
matter to desire, in the sense, you can say there are other issues
that also divide people, but. Sure.
Yeah.
Doesn't, doesn't make religion irrelevant. Is, is
religious faith different in some,
would we say, would we, I mean? Would,
is it qualitatively different in some way?
Well, I, I think some of the things that you have mentioned, mention make a difference
in terms of attachment.
I, I think also that it's a, a
maybe it's, it has analogs other like ideologies
often, say, say, marxism is an ideology served almost like religion, defined the self. It
define the social relations. It defined the good.
It provide the whole universe in which a person moved, unlike, say, soccer club, right.
This is overarching thing in which you, you, you situate yourself and all the other relations
and if you, and if you connect that with also powerful emotional attachments,
it's really a powerful thing.